hey youtubers it's Charlie hopefully you
guys have had a chance to process the
big WTF Game of Thrones ending just
remember that George Martin says never
take anything as gospel so it's not over
till the actually roll credits on the
final episode of the final season these
will be my season six predictions and as
is tradition they have some new cast
members coming in that I'll do a video
for at some point there's still a couple
book things that they have left to do
for the most part the show has caught up
with the books with book 5 wins the
winner is supposed to be out before
season 6 next year but I'm not going to
bank on that it could happen if it does
that'd be wonderful I'm also doing an
extra giveaway as part of this video
it's a $20 Amazon gift card all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video but here we go
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet what I'm gonna do
is I'm just going to go through each of
the storylines and just do predictions
that way starting with Brienne and
Podrick in case it wasn't evident from
the episode Gwendoline Christie said
that she missed Sansa scandal and she'll
probably find out about that and being
super crushed she said that she felt
like Brienne had been sitting there for
weeks waiting to see something it also
shoots down theories that Sansa and reek
might run into Brienne and a lot of you
guys are wondering is Stannis still
alive we didn't see that sword run
through his face as his tradition with
shows like Game of Thrones they're not
dead till their head is chopped off in
the body is burned I still think she did
kill him but the whole point of Stannis
a storyline in the finale is letting us
know that he is not Ozora hi his armies
decimated he has no more heirs as
essentially the Baratheon line safe for
Gendry is dead his King's blood is
spilling out so he really has nothing to
offer in the war for the dawn
so Brienne and Podrick are probably
going to shift their attention back to
Sansa at Winterfell or who they think is
still at Winterfell that means she'll
have the Bolton's in Ramsay in her
target sites so we might get to see some
Brienne versus Ramsay moving on -
Samwell and Gilly this is actually a
pretty easy one they're going to old
town they were scouting locations at
places that look like they could double
for Old Town so we could see that place
in season six and I don't think that
they would show us Old Town without
showing us the outside of building so
it's not going to be like just the
inside of a library that they could be
shooting in any studio anywhere old town
is like the next big place in Westeros
we haven't
aside from Highgarden think about the
Citadel it's like the biggest location
of learning and knowledge in Westeros so
of course the series is going to have to
go there at a certain point there's
really only a couple places in the world
Samwell can go to get information about
fighting the White Walkers and that
would be the Citadel or it would be like
a shy way over in the east there just
aren't that many places it takes a long
time to become a maester though so I
don't think that Samwell will be a
maester at the end of the series it
takes way longer than the two or so
years that we have left
moving on to Sansa and Riku the last
time we saw him were jumping off the
battlements at Winterfell I know
everyone wondered you know are they dead
no they jumped into like a giant
snowbank you have to remember that the
snow is like six feet deep of all the
likely places they could go
Sansa knows that her brother is still
alive in Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch so I mean she doesn't know that he
just got the snapped out of him so
they could head there for protection or
they could head for Theon's family they
could head towards the Iron Islands we
do have that pirate character that
sounds an awful lot like Yount Greyjoy
coming onto the show so we could see
more Ironborn stuff it makes sense that
reek would try to go to his family's
home that being said I think that Sansa
is gonna be the one to take charge and I
think that she would want to go for the
wall just because it's a familiar place
she hasn't been there but she knows that
it's heavily fortified in there men that
will protect her little does she know
about the white Walker armor in the
night's king that's gonna be a bit of an
eye-opener
and a lot of your asking about which
personality is gonna win out you know
will reek turn back into Theon or will
he be just crazy reek for the rest of
season six the show is playing it down
the middle he does seem cognizant of his
life as the end he still remembers
things he remembers Theon Greyjoy the
book version of reek is a little crazier
but I think he's gonna be more of the
same he'll be more like he was this
season he will never go back to being
the Theon Greyjoy before he met Ramsay
Bolton
speaking of which on to Ramsay in the
Bolton's what's going on with them they
just kicked the out of Stannis's
army and Ramsay looks like he's having
the time of his life killing all the
survivors and a lot of people are upset
we didn't get to see the pink letter but
I do think we'll see some things from
that storyline they'll find that Sansa
is gone and they'll have to replace her
so that the other lords of the north
will still listen to the Bolton's they
were using Sansa to maintain their hold
on the north because the people of the
north
loyal to the Starks and as long as
there's a stark in Winterfell there's
the promise that they will do whatever
the Bolton's ask if like the Karstarks
and the other lords of the north were to
find out that Sansa had escaped they
would probably try to track her down
rally around her and start a new war in
the north
so the Bolton's are going to do
everything they can to prevent that from
happening look at their army though this
is a huge army what's going to happen
with that well if they don't start a war
with the Lannisters then they'll
probably get taken out by the white
walker army when they move south of the
wall which it is very possible that we
could see you know why else would you
neutralize Jon Snow in the story that
the only person who cared about
preventing the White Walkers from
getting south if you didn't want the
White Walkers to get south so the
Bolton's in their army aren't just gonna
like sit around in Winterfell all year
next year there will probably be some
conflict with either King's Landing or
some of the other Lords of the north
don't forget about Littlefinger either
he's probably try and take advantage of
that situation in the north
remember he wants control moving down to
King's Landing so we have to talk about
Cersei versus the faith we met Robert
strong who is the zombie mountain he's
the mountain that's been lying on Qyburn
stable all year in the books it's
implied that he doesn't have a head so I
was a little disappointed to see that he
very clearly had a head on the show but
I can understand why they did it that
way for practical reasons there's still
a couple things from the books that they
have not passed yet and I think that one
of those will be this Cersei plot if you
have read the books you probably know
what I'm talking about just please use
spoiler tags when you're gonna talk
about it but think about it as being a
slight twist of Tyrians trial last
season it'll be almost the exact same
thing just you know flipped on its head
I think the real surprise is who Robert
strong is gonna end up fighting and no
I'm not expecting cleganebowl but not to
Jaime and Myrcella so the last we saw
them it looked like Marcella was gonna
die
she could survive she's still alive in
the books she just gets maimed what is
Jaime gonna do about it though trystane
is on that boat so I mean he's play not
gonna kill him because he doesn't want
to start a war with Dorne this is one of
those things that could drive Jaime over
the edge he who's trying to be like the
good dad that's the whole reason he went
to Dorne they are filming in Dorne next
year so we will get more of the sand
snakes in Turan Martell but I don't
think they're gonna turn that boat
around I sure do hope Qyburn has some
medicine for that poison would it not be
ridiculous to see like zombie Myrcella
like Heiberg
her just like he raised the mountain she
will be changed sir moving over to the
east up what about Daenerys in that
khalasar very clearly there a couple
things that have to happen she's gonna
have to win over the new Khal she might
even have to get married to him so it'll
be like a twist on what happened in
season one where she married Khal Drogo
to she could win them over with drogon
after he recovers but I don't think
that's going to be happening in the
first or second episodes I fully expect
as is the tradition with Game of Thrones
that Season six Episode one will pick up
immediately after the finale leaves off
it looks like drogon could be out of
commission for at least a couple
episodes long enough for Jorah and
Daario to find her and for the three of
them to try and figure something out but
yes I do think that she will add those
Dothraki soldiers to her fold eventually
over the course of season six
she is the united slowly uniting the
east but I mean it's a big place so she
still want to just got a fraction of it
what about tyrion and varys and marine
though and a lot of you were asking is
Varys the harpy was he the one
controlling all those people is totally
possible I mean that would be a twist
I'm not expecting it he'll be successful
in marine in a way that he was not
successful in King's Landing or I should
say he was successful in King's Landing
but nobody gave him any credit for it
but he won't be beloved in the way that
Daenerys is beloved people just won't
on him as much they have a whole
lot of in marine though so he
should be just fine Walter nurses away
tyrion and varys the scenes are always a
lot of fun not quite as funny as Tyrion
and Jorah but we have Daario and Jorah
so I think that that's where a lot of
the comedy will flow in the eastern
storyline as much as a lot of goes
down on the show there's always a lot of
comedy from unusual pairings like Aria
in the Hound speedy which on to blind
Arya so we are basically up to wins a
winner with arias storyline she's a
survivor she will slowly get used to
being blind but I don't think any of us
ever expects her to fully become a
faceless person she'll continue to learn
more about the many-faced God in the
faceless men but I think at a certain
point you know after she regains her
sight she will leave that might get
pushed into Season seven but I think
that her programming her base
programming is Arya Stark and that list
will always win out so do not be
surprised if needle makes a reappearance
sometime during season six on to the
main event though
snow the wildlings Melisandre everybody
up at the wall starting with Jon Snow of
course the big conversation here is what
Kit Harington has been saying he said in
interviews that David Nutter the
director told him he's dead and he had a
very Tony Soprano type talk with Dan and
Dave about his character dying so what
does that mean
most likely that his character is
medically pronounced dead like his heart
is beating his brain activity is slowing
down but they didn't burn the body so
what's going to happen in Episode one
will probably at least see the body
but when Kit Harington says that he's
not coming back I think the language
that he uses is very important so I
think that what Dan and Dave mean is
that Jon Snow is not coming back he will
come back but he will be changed in the
way that Lady Stoneheart is changed from
Catelyn Stark she is not the same
character when she comes back she's a
completely new identity so think of that
in terms of Jon Snow there are a couple
tinfoil theories about how he could have
survived but I don't think he survived I
think he's actually dead so a
resurrection will be required if he's
not taken north of the wall and co-opted
by the White Walkers
if Kit Harington sits out season six in
the way that brand sat out season five
it could be because someone takes his
body north of the wall and we just we
don't see what happens with him what
does this mean in terms of what's going
on at the wall because Melisandre Davos
in the Nights Watch are still there they
still have a job to do keep the White
Walkers from getting through I don't
think they would have done this to Jon
Snow if they did not want the walkers to
get through like we need to get to the
point in season seven when White Walkers
are south of the wall and there's this
giant battle in Westeros like when
there's snow coming down on King's
Landing in order for that to happen the
White Walkers need to bring down the
wall and they can't do that if you have
really smart people that know how to
fight them at the wall and that was Jon
Snow the rest of the Nights Watch like
Alliser thorne here they're a bunch of
ass hats they're going down like a sack
of potatoes the minute the White Walkers
march on the wall in the books
Melisandre talks about how at the wall
her power is at its greatest the TV show
changed things a little bit she never
actually went with Stannis when he
marched on Winterfell she always stayed
at the wall presumably the show sent her
back to the wall so that she could deal
with this Jon Snow's situation
and keep this in mind to Kit Harington
we just photographed recently in Ireland
where the cast shoots they haven't
started shooting season six yet that
happens in a couple months but why would
he stick around with the rest of the
cast if he wasn't going to be part of
the next season so will at least see his
body in Episode one he could sit the
season out like he could mysteriously
disappear is someone could take his body
but I do feel like he will come back
it's just like everything in the book
narrative points towards him being a big
figure in the war for the dawn the
biggest thing being that at the end of
the war the White Walkers will form a
truce with the humans and John Snow will
become a future night's King to help
protect that treaty north of the wall
all just speculation but I do think I
just I do feel like we will see the wall
come down sometime before season seven
is over it's just too big of a moment to
not deliver on it'd be like this big
spectacular special effects sequence
like one of those episodes that they
show in IMAX
so here's my big question for you guys
why do you think that Kit Harington and
Danny Dave are so adamant about Jon Snow
not coming back do you think it's all
misdirection and that Kit Harington will
come back as a different character I
know it might seem like things are over
for like the next nine months but I will
be doing weekly bonus videos going
forward so don't worry I'll keep doing
plenty of Game of Thrones videos it'll
all be okay but I think I'm going to do
for my next bonus video is a breakdown
of all the resurrections that have
happened on the snow including the red
gods resurrections as well as the White
Walkers resurrections just a reminder
that in my Q&A video tomorrow I'll
announce the winner of the giveaway of
this video and my book giveaway my
finale video if you have no idea what's
going on with that just be sure to check
out my finale video what you guys wait
for that Q&A to post you can click here
for my finale video and you can click
here to learn all about Aegon the
Conqueror in the early history of the
Targaryen family thank you so much
watching you guys are all awesome
everybody let's high-five I'll see you
guys tomorrow
Oh